feeling
it's for absence please um apologies
received from council barca
chair thank you
further apologies
now item two then decorations of
interest
members are requested to declare the
existence and nature of any disposable
peculiar interest
and or other interests not already on
their register of interest
in any item on the agenda withdrawal
from the meeting at the appropriate time
who's writing three minutes to the last
meeting so can we approve please the
minutes of the meeting held on the 30th
of september 2020.
do you have a proposal please yes
do we have a second uh
second chair thank you
all in favor
[Music]
thank you and that's carried thank you
so item 4 then reports of the internal
audit consortium manager
so over to you please jenny
thank you chair uh jenny williams
internal audit consortium manager
um so this report summarizes the audits
that we've completed since the last
meeting
and it also gives you an update on the
progress on our 2021 internal audit plan
and if you turn to appendix two of the
report this period we've issued five
reports
four that have received substantial
assurance and one with reasonable
assurance
those are our top two categories so it's
it's an excellent set of results
particularly
at these difficult times um i don't as a
consequence feel that there's any
particular issues that i need to bring
to your attention
we didn't identify any fraud and so the
next part
of the report is the progress on the
2021 plan
and appendix 3 of the report um
shows you what's in the plan and what
we've covered
um so we've issued nine reports to date
and we've got us
further six audits in progress
um i have had a mid-review of progress
with the plan with the section 151
officer
um where we discussed any potential
risks arising from covert 19.
um at this point in time we feel that
the current plan is still
appropriate and we will gear our testing
towards ensuring
that covert 19 hasn't detrimentally
affected the controls in place
and if any significant risks do emerge
we still may need to
to vary the plan and but given the
current situation i feel that we're
making reasonable progress on the plan
um but it is likely that some areas we
will need to carry over
to 21 22. so the recommendation is that
the report be noted
and that the impact of coronavirus on
our ability to complete the
plan be noted and approved
and i'll try and answer any questions
chair thank you thank you any clients or
questions
no that's straightforward then so we
move to item to section six which are
the recommendations which are set out at
six point one six point two
do you have a proposal please
[Music]
thank you council club do we have a
second uh thank you council armitage all
in favor
thank you those recommendations are
carried
so staying with the internal internal
audit consulting manager for
the next part please audit
recommendations
thank you chair um yes so the purpose of
this report
is to try and provide some details on
the number of audit recommendations that
we've made
and that we've implemented and to try
and flag if there's any areas of concern
so appendix one that provides an
overview
um and you can see that from 2018-19
93 of the recommendations have been
implemented
so we've just got nine out of 134 that
are outstanding
um and none of those are high priority
um eight percent of 1920 recommendations
have been implemented
um so whilst you can see there are still
some to be implemented
there are none that's a high priority um
and i would also like to add that it
should be recognized that due to covid19
it will have had an impact on officer's
ability
to implement some of these
recommendations or just to ensure that
performs updated
um the next pages in the report provides
details of the areas that have
outstanding recommendations
and also again shows it shows the full
picture for the current year
where we've issued nine reports eight
was substantial and one with reasonable
um 26 pages 26 to 32
they detail every recommendation
outstanding
along with any comments that managers
have had to make
so again and given the current
circumstances i think that the progress
made
is reasonable and i'm happy to try and
answer any questions
thank you any comments or questions
now just one for myself um regards to
with regards to the business continuity
and emergency planning
um i've noted that its priority is set
down as medium and the original target
date is
april 2020. given that you've
mentioned covid and we are where we are
um will that priority be revised
and will the date be brought forward
because
i think business is particularly
concerned at this moment in time
yeah i think uh business continuity
plans are something both
um the executive directors have been
have been
looking at and certainly something we'll
be um
trying to look at and get a full picture
of the in the new year
and so we will discuss those um
and and check that they're up to date so
to answer to my question will the
priority target be changed to high
um we until we sort of review an area
again and look at it again we don't or
automatically update the
priority at that point in time and but
when
when we review it again and if it's not
been implemented at that stage then we
would look to
moving it up to high i'm getting a no
then
so um can can this be on the next
agenda please because i think i think
business continuity plan is is it
absolutely vital for the north east
derbyshire
district and i think the fact it's only
medium and we're leaving till april 2020
in my submission is not urgent enough
and
it should be put on to the next agenda
and then we can look at it
in a bit more detail um i mean the april
2020 is when it would have been
implemented by so it may be that the
officer just hasn't
updated perform at this stage to say
that that's been completed
yeah no i'm the section 151 officer
can i ask you to just come in on this
please certainly chair
maybe a way forward jenny is that this
should be maybe
moved up in the plan you know the review
of the plan
if business continuity is obviously a
priority this year
there has been quite a lot of work done
maybe an audit of those business
plans is timely without help
i think so i hope the committee would
support that i think i'm sure people
would agree that uh
business continuity is absolutely
essential
yes i i agree with you there chair it's
absolutely essential there are companies
going bust left right and center and
we've got to keep
a hand on this and it is very
important and should be done with the
utmost speed
thank you underlining the point
councilman there councillorship man
are we supposed to get these on a
regular basis like how often are they
reviewed
uh somebody's saying they might be uh
increased when they're reviewed
like is it every six months every three
months yeah we're doing it on the
on the timely in the time we weigh in
the next one was going through six
months time
and so we were going to the end six
months but i'm just drawing out from the
plan something that
perhaps needs a bit more immediacy
yes chair we can have a look at business
continuity arrangements after after
christmas
thank you thank you are there any other
comments from anyone
if not then can we move to uh the
recommendations at 6.1 and 6.2
um it says that to further update your
votes in six months time at 6.2 but of
course we've just
um added an additional one which is 6.3
that the business continuity can be
brought to the next
meeting of this audit committee so
with those in that edition in mind can
we have a proposal please that the
recommendation will be accepted thank
you councilman
second
targets so that's tomorrow
you're mute though i didn't think we'd
still be saying this after
all these months
okay thank you very much chair um just
this is the
q2 report from july to september for the
council plan targets
um just to note as well that there is a
review going on at the moment
and the reason being 1.2 a number of
times have been selected for review due
to the impact and ongoing challenges of
coban 19.
there has been some housekeeping
undertaking so
some removable operational targets that
overlap and the report is going to go to
camera in december
so what i intend to do if it's okay with
the
meeting is to go through the summary of
the um
the target by a theme and there's also
appendix that highlights all the targets
if there's any further information
required
so for the first theme it's our economy
in the theme there are 29 targets in
total nine to the
nine of the targets are on track 17
targets are under review as noted above
and the three targets have been affected
by covid
are the the four
eke eco 13 hold four events annually
with further
and higher education establishments so
as you can imagine with the code
restrictions
restrictions this has been difficult
there are going to be
invites there was an invite to a virtual
jobs affair which was
successful and further events are being
discussed with universities
eco 14 so deliver the avenue schools
challenge annually so again with the
schools being closed
and due to key withdrawing their support
the school involved are
being supported by linking them with
other development sites
when the schools are able to consider
site visits
and the final one for this theme is eco
20
review resources to ensure tourism is
the focus of the
economic development team by april 2020
so there's just been an initial delay
caused by resources
which has been covered related there are
two interns
that have been recruited to the post to
the to support the tourism role
and subject to any covered and any
restrictions that should be imposed by
december january time
and there is the longer term resource
provision will be included
in the restructure of the economic
development team
so moving on to the environment theme
there are 16 targets in total under the
environment
five targets are on track three are
under review
and there's one target that's been
placed on alerts
so an alert is where we anticipate the
the target won't be metal in the next
six months
and it's just to raise awareness that it
might need an extension
and this is to deliver four proactive
planning enforcement exercises per year
so the planning enforcement team
continue to work proactively
to address environmental issues that
arise however delivering
proactive enforcement exercises have
proven difficult at the moment
due to enforcement capacity and
recruitment issues
so this target is unlikely to be met for
2021
and there are seven targets under the
environment theme
that have been affected by covid so
the first one is published uh publish
the adopted planning enforcement
protocol by the first of april 2020
so protocol has been considered by
council
and it's due to be rolled out in quarter
three and again code
affected the following one complete the
review of planning enforcement resources
by the first of april so again this
stems from the one above
and again with a similar update in terms
of the um
the delay caused by covert envir
environment 08 so developer climate
change communication strategy by march
2020
so again the communications team
had to prioritize the the covid
awareness so they've requested an
extension to april 2021 to be
complete and this one this target will
go to cabinet for approval
and env 09 to deliver
develop and deliver to climate change
community information events per year
it's for the school climate change event
as postponed due to close occurring 19
or social distancing in the school time
table it means it's not yet possible to
confirm
an additional date again with a similar
similar in mind deliver one climate
change training event for parish
councils per year
so this has been affected by covert as
well and it is due to be
it is scheduled to be delivered at the
district parish liaison group
on the 26th of march next year
the following two increase the number of
fixed penalty notices for
litter and dog filing by 20 and
undertake
15 litter picks i love where you live
initiatives
both of these initiatives have been
temporarily suspended due to the
outbreak
moving on to our residence theme so
there are 30 targets in total
12 times on track six targets are under
review to go to cabinet
and there are 12 targets that have been
affected by curving 19.
and again i won't go through each one of
them but a lot of these
being under our residence is about
leisure and leisure facilities been
affected
so the first one is about whilst
ensuring high quality leisure facilities
reduce the annual subsidy year on year
so again the leisure facilities
open on the 25th of july with covered
restrictions and they're operating
within the guidance
so again it wasn't a full quarter of
them being open
similar with increasing participation
this has been affected
um rvs04 deliver a health intervention
for 258 new attendance per year again
with the lockdown
the most of the scheme has been inactive
there was a target
in place of 64. and we've managed to hit
eight
in this quarter but again with
facilities opening
today it you know there is a
there's a plan in place res 07
deliver additional lunchtime or
after-school ph clubs
for at least six schools per year so
this has been affected
moving on to the communications and
similar with the communications team
commence direct electronic
communications will list a thousand
residents by
december 2020 so the council is
investing in an electronic messaging
service
and undertaken relevant training in
october
2020 currently there are 500 to 100 000.
sorry to put it across you because we've
got all this in the report on page 35.
okay are you reading what's on page 35
to us
yes right is that how you i'm i'm going
to contend that we don't need you to
read out
phase 35 and 36 or we've got it all
listed
okay would you mind perhaps if um if we
took comments and questions at this
stage rather than you
yeah that all councils will have read
yeah
by all means i can just give a
conclusion and then
yeah so after the 105 targets in total
and 42 are on track which is 40 25
which is 24 percent have been affected
by covert one has been achieved behind
target
eight of them achieved previously and
there is one that's on an alert that's
unlikely to be achieved in 2021
so yes i can open up for questions thank
you thank you any comments or questions
from the committee
council armitage
uh thank you chair it's to do with uh
1.3 uh eco
14 about uh kia
uh withdrawing their support uh
will they uh will they come back with
support for this
or do we have to look for somebody else
in the future
again i can finally find the answer
chair
and then respond back to yourself and
council armitage
okay i think from my point of view i
think kia had put that on while they
were doing the development
and i think in terms of the project
itself there were some
question marks over it because um the
idea was to support northeast armstrong
district schools
and i'm afraid the schools involved
weren't all
northeast armstrong district schools
somewhere from chesterfield borough
and questions were asked about the
appropriateness of that we wanted
district schools in there that was one
of the areas that we were going to
review
in any case so
i think if we look to see if there's any
more support from business with regard
to a school
challenge would be welcome in any case
because i think it's important in terms
of
promoting interest in industry and so on
but we we must make sure this is my
opinion i'm sure people agree
that they're district schools
okay i agree with you on that district
schools only
thank you any other comments or
questions council row
thank you john just i'm just picking up
on the bit that he was reading out
resolution 10 how does it what what do
we mean by an electoral communication is
that text message system
yes i'm going to then resolution 10 on
page 35
the direct electronic communications and
i think that's a suite of
um again i would have to speak to the
the communications manager so that's a
suite of
emails and also uh mns and direct
messaging of that type in order to
make contact with them with residents
but again i can get a fuller explanation
for you
and i think i'm gonna bring lee hicken
in yeah
thank you chair yeah it directly relates
to
the purchase of a system called granicus
that's the
uh latest system we've got it basically
a familiar with
uh tellers once and things like that
where systems work and communicate
together so once you've registered
you're pulling information from all all
over the place so it kind of works as a
holistic system if you like right okay
registering for certain services not
talking to each other granicus allows us
to communicate
openly outwardly with our customers and
also pull together relevant information
for them when they
dial in through that system if you like
so they can access all sorts of things
it's something county council's had in a
while
and it seems to be really successful so
we've gone through the process of
procuring that and
we'll be insta installing that soon uh
in terms of
other things that are associated with
that we've been moving
a shift towards electronic
communications or or transferring as
many people who are
happy to do that online for
many many months and that's grown
exponentially you know i've not got the
figures at hand unfortunately but
we've moved a hell of a lot online
particularly some of the heavy
enquiry uh the things that kind of clog
the phone lines up if you like like
missed bins and such things as that
so it's all interlinked but that that
one in particular relates to this
granicus
purchase thank you i i think
my only concern was as we know
throughout the district there are people
that aren't very
i.t savvy computer you know et cetera
and they won't just be lost i think that
was before they're going to be able to
use the services as we ordinarily would
do now i think that was my calling
so yeah if i could answer could it
yes please obviously it's an important
point so yes i think
there's people like me that still use
quill and parchment so i'm interested in
responding
you and me both chair yeah three of us
because
you're right what this allows us to do
is create additional capacity for those
people
whereas people who are happy to and
you'll know many of them
uh who are more than happy in fact it's
their
preference to do things online uh you
know i've got one parent
that does that and one parent that
doesn't so
there will always be is this is not a
way of eradicating
the traditional what it does is frees up
time to be able to deal with the
traditional and perhaps even give them
more capacity to do it by moving some of
the others online
thank you perfect thank you thank you
chair thank you
that's reassuring i think obviously
there's got to be a mix you know we're
living in the 21st century but
of course we also have to think about
the cross
range of residents who aren't all right
literally as well
do the comments or questions
counter shipment yeah we're just um you
know on that
m13 the target seems a bit back to front
to me
because the target there is to increase
the amount of
fouling offenses by 20 yes
rather than surely the target should be
like reduced doug fouling by 20.
let's just increase the number of fixed
penalty notices issued
by 20 yeah that seems to me like a
the wrong target doesn't it you know
what i mean like it's supposed to be
the target needs to be what the issue is
that there's lots more dogmas
the target needs to be reducing that
dogmas not finding people
ideally we want less fines going out
because that means that dogfile is
reduced
yeah i agree with your point among
comments on that um
again these are yeah again these are set
by the environmental
health managers as well i suppose it's
it depends what your perspective is i
suppose in terms of
increasing the you can work both ways i
know we hand out um
dog fouling bags as well and it's just
being
proactive and reactive um
i'm sure councilman won't mind me
underlining it is that
by increasing the number of fixed term
penalties for dog fouling
you're almost implying that we're
getting better at catching people dog
filing rather than
reducing the actual dog fouling itself
so the success would be a reduced amount
of fixed penalty notices because stock
founding is
on the decrease i think that's absolute
shot of it
i bring in thank you chair yeah
absolutely get your point understand it
completely
um it's a bit like the flighty pin and
waste
so yes of course we want to reduce
the offense happening in the first place
and and some of that's about
communication some of it though
is about the threat of enforcement and
it's the the enforcement side of the
ambition of the council if you like to
get better at enforcement
that's driven that particular kpi but
it's not
a single it shouldn't be viewed as one
single
uh objective you know it's it's it's
more than that we
we prefer if we weren't handing any out
but we've got to be
keen our customers and our communities
would want us
to be enforcing against those who were
ignoring things
you know i think luckily according to
this dogs don't foul during kobe
so um
so we're okay and i think i think the
serious point is if we find
our country more counselor um if
if environmental just look at that the
wording around that
and and perhaps we'll get a kpi that
perhaps better points to the success of
decreased
dog fouling in the district rather than
taking more people to task i guess you'd
i guess what you'd monitor chair is the
how many reports of dog fouling you got
and hopefully that decreased because if
that's decreasing that means it's
appearing to be less of a problem for
people that seems like a kpi that i'd
follow
yes i think we'll take that in
consideration if we let environment come
up with a
sort of a remodeled kpi so we're saying
we can look at it next time it comes
back to us
yeah uh just to take uh the point that
we're handing dog fouling bags out i
inquired and i was told that it had now
been stopped
and the other thing is uh there'll be
far more dog fouling
incidents happening because more and
more people are walking
and they're taking the dog with them and
i found that all around ash over
and when they are taking the bag with
them you find it chucked in the hedges
uh rather than take it taken away and
you know it's just one of the things
that
seems to be happening more and more
people are walking and they're checking
their dogs with them
thank you for that uh insight into dog
parliament
thank you so um
i think the point has been made so um
we'll look at that kpi please so that um
it can be better measured and from my
point of view as well i think
i was disappointed to see um
m05 on page 34 environment
5 about proactive planning enforcement
we all as district board members will
know that planning
enforcement is extremely important
and i'm sure the committee again will
help me to underline the point that
we need enforcement in the district and
to say that the target is unlikely to be
met at 20 20 21
[Music]
is disappointing it is disappointing
and so i'm sure that um environmental
services i know there's issues around
recruitment and so on
you know that's accepted and but i hope
that it'll be
additional thought given to recruiting
enforcement officers it's essential
my other one is environment zero eight
develop a climate change communication
strategy
um extension has sought the cabinet
for april 21 um
climate hasn't stopped just because of
colvid
and again we are still dealing with
climate change
issues throughout this and um
and i know several parish councils are
still thinking about climate change
issues
and i know three
[Music]
uh where around myself that are still
developing climate change strategies
working on action plans and so on they
haven't stopped because of code so why
is district
signaling that it has i'm a bit
concerned to read this so is there an
officer that can explain that
lee thank you
so yeah i agree with you climate hasn't
stopped in fact
we've made some good progress
um there's any particular silver lining
uh
in terms of carbon reduction throughout
this period
one thing i can add with the obviously
not in the performance report
and sort of
recent intervention we've we as north of
these dubs you've come up with
three games that we'd like to roll out
county-wide
uh one is a major campaign called flanks
of torn
day at reducing household missions
on the household within the next year
and rolling that county world obviously
can you can understand the potential the
second one is
around uh hard to treat homes dealing
with that
on a county-wide footprint and accessing
government funding to be able to do that
and that really is
uh millions of tons of emissions
and and the potential for a national
flagship scheme there and the third one
is around
a coordinated approach to electric
vehicle infrastructure charging across
the county north east arms you're
leading on these three
projects and we've got support from
across the county that they want to
piggyback and be a part of this so
that is good news but i i accept
the point about the communications
strategy
i'll see if we can bring that forward a
little bit sooner than that
because it is important the biggest
impact we can have we've done
so many things internally but the
biggest impact we can have is actually
outside of our organization
so i'm happy to take that away as an
action for myself
thank you very much for sharing that
information because it shows that the
district is
addressing large um ideas to
combat climate change and difficulties
around that but
we don't seem to be making that public
knowledge so therefore communication
strategy will be key so if that brought
forward rather than
what's been suggested here thank you for
taking that
as an action my other one
is services on page 36 ser
12 car parking patrols are undertaken
outside schools
temporarily suspended apparently because
of covered
well schools are still operating car
parking issues outside
schools in this district is still a
major problem
and i think everyone on here can point
to a prime school in their ward and
kayla polymor side you name it where
there are car parking problems
and the fact that we started well with
uh dealing with car parking patrols
which was well received by residents
stopped because of coverage well the car
parking issues as far as i'm concerned
the world council
still haven't gone away and and
i think it would be a good idea to see
how we can get back on
track with all of that lee can i ask you
to comment on that
uh yes you can chair by all means
i'll have to uh i'll have to take it
away i don't know
a great deal about it but i can
certainly uh feedback
the feelings of this group and yourself
and see if we can
turn that around and see what see what
we can do i'm not sure how reliant on
others we are but i agree with you
entirely you know the schools are still
open travel
will be an issue so i'll see what we can
do about that
the reason i'm bringing it up now
because it's we're coming up to winter
nights are dark there's more likelihood
of
a car parking issue a child being
injured
because of dark nights around schools i
just think
um you know something that's
important to me but i'm sure i'm hoping
the wrestling committee will
support that
any other comments or questions
just chipman thanks chair um just back
on the climate thing i don't know if
anyone saw
um the con it was
where does the consultation on their
climate change that we've recently put
out
but it was one of the worst
questionnaires i've ever seen in my life
and it didn't actually ask people what
they thought about
like what they you know and i did they
have any ideas
did how could they help it was very much
do you are you aware of climate change
or something do you know that heating
the home is the best way to heat home
and it was very
bland for starts and it didn't really it
didn't it was more the council asking
people what
um what they knew really rather than
you know can you contribute and feed
into some kind of
report or something at the end it just
seemed very bland and like didn't really
achieve anything in fact i shared it
around a bit and then
i almost got a bit embarrassed once i
should have been through it myself
because it just didn't achieve anything
so i just wondered if that's
been looked at and actually is there
gonna be a more
wider reaching consultation that's
actually going to bring people in like
you say lee
i mean it's people ultimately that are
going to drive this
they're going to have the ideas there's
probably people that are more educated
in this field than
me or anybody else sat in this meeting
and then it's wasted talent
we really need to get them involved
rather than it be in the council talking
to people
rather than listening head of page
service comments again
yes no problem at all
i'll pick up your last point first if i
can council shipments so
i agree with you in terms of uh
everyone doing their bit is where the
real impact is going to happen
uh outside of legislation and things
like that
so the thanks a ton campaign
is very very much aligned to that
so it helps people there's an emissions
calculator in it
where people can tell you there's a
quick lookup reference
table within the actual uh landing page
that
people can pledge to do simple things
like turning
the heating down by one degree 156 kilos
of
carbon saved per year those kind of
things and this is more about
that engagement the the uh
survey that you're speaking of i'm not
absolutely intimate with it
but i do know it was for for a
particular reason and it was more about
getting in our uh
our environmental health team in in
making contact with people who needed
support and help
rather than
thanks
you know hopefully some big really big
wins at the end of that one
thank you cheers thank you i think on
behalf of the committee thank you omar
for your report
my only comment finally is that um
25 out of 105 targets have been
registered as affected by clothing 19
that's nearly a quarter and in my
submission there were quite a few in
there that if we were to trawl through
and go back to the offices concern
we could turn the status away from being
cold infected
now that we know for example that two
interns have been recruited to support
the tourism role we can
change that coding for example um
there's others in there that i think a
conversation with
the essential officers about the
communication strategy for climate
change we can change
all those codings from purple to either
getting back on track or the reality for
some of them will be
behind track or maybe
it's just not relevant anymore and would
therefore be under review
so i think status could be changed
and so i think that's an exercise for
you
to challenge officers and ask them about
to codeword effective is it really code
effective we can't move any further
forward
or can that status change to what it
ought to be
yes sure i'll note that and the the
other points that you've raised
for the next meeting and with the
performance manager
thank you thank you so much as any other
comments or questions remove the
recommendations at 6.1 that the
quarterly app turns
be noted for these targets can we have a
proposal please i'll move them chairs
thank you and second about council
armitage all in favor
thank you that is carried so we move now
to
item six reports the director of
corporate resources and head of paid
service over to you please leave on risk
management
thank you chair and thank you to members
of the committee for inviting us
along to do a report so the purpose of
the report is basically to
provide an update on the risk management
arrangements and the strategic risk
register
as things stand today so i know
you've within your pack you've got the
risk management strategy attached i
don't intend on going through that
but uh that was approved by a cabinet in
march
2020 and there has been some delay
in getting the actions actioned if you
like because
it was all hands on deck covered um
in during march and it has been since so
although like i said it was improved in
march
uh it took us until summer to get the
inaugural meeting of the
risk management group uh together which
we which we've done now
which is which is good and at 1.9
i've provided an update of what that
risk management group
has been doing and looking at we've got
we've got a
we've got a uh the second meeting
either next week or the week after of
this group so i will hopefully by the
next
time we get to this next meeting we'll
have an even more comprehensive update
but essentially
the group have reviewed the risk
registers
they've looked at the emerging risks
we've reviewed the strategy because this
was the first time the group met i
needed
everybody in the group to be fully aware
of what we're trying to achieve
uh and obviously the kovid specific
issues that are very present
uh today so at 1.13
you'll notice that in the strategic risk
register
the the biggest change to it at this
stage because it's still being reviewed
now is that we've added a specific one
around
copied 19. within the strategic risk
register we've always had one for
business continuity and emergency
planning
arrangements this is an in addition to
that so
they need to be viewed together
but the list of the risks and the
consequences identified in there and
then the action
to mitigate against those risks
is also included which includes the fact
that we are very well embedded within
the local resilience forum
uh and the network of subgroups uh
you'll hear
you've heard reports from karen
on a regular basis in different forums
uh
around kobe we we've done extremely well
i think
in in getting plugged into that whole
network and contributing to it
so that's identified in in the register
now
the other thing i'd add without reading
the report word for word is
really to underline a point that was
made earlier by
the uh chair and and others
about audit and where our focus
may or may not be the intention of this
risk management group is very much about
also having an influence on our own
internal audit program because
we ought to be focusing on areas of
greatest risk
uh and i think that's an ec that's
something that's accepted by jenny
and others on that group so the
recommendations
chair at 6.1 the committee notes the
report and the strategic risk register
and i'm happy to take any questions on
that
but i would finally i like to say we
hope to bring this back regularly a
report
that is a dynamic one a retrospective
one
uh setting out what what the risk
management group does
each time so it'll be a move-in feast
rather than a
cut-and-paste job
thank you well you you're almost beating
me to my next question really about this
because
the risk management group we don't know
the membership of it
and why nobody from audit is part of
that risk management group which would
be my first question
and it seems that we're discussing audit
type
considerations and yet no one from audi
is on there
apart from officers um sorry
jenny yeah apart from officers um yeah
we do
have no elected member from this group
the other thing is um accountability
so you're saying that we will now start
to receive reports
uh section 151 officers will probably
guess what we're going to say next
will it be old news because there's no
point in having something that's already
been talked about and dealt with at risk
management group
and that we have had no input we're just
almost told as a fatal complete
that that's what's been decided and
that's that rather than having an
input and was being able to shake
documents and maybe make some
suggestions or at least say from the
audit
that our recommendations are x y and z
i don't believe in having them
retrospectively there'd be no point
okay can i uh julie
so two things first of all i would
absolutely welcome uh somebody from audi
committee to sit on the risk management
group i think that's a great suggestion
it is elected member ladies the
portfolio elder
uh for finance and resources council
parking who chairs the group
i i see absolutely no reason and i think
it would be beneficial for a member of
this committee to be on that group
in terms of the report uh
i accept what's just been said and
and uh either a forward plan
element uh within the report might be
useful for this group
so that this group can feed directly
into it but
certainly a member of this group on it
i'd be happy for that castle [ __ ] and
i i'm not sure if you want to uh
suggest a nominee
i'm not looking for extra work for
myself although i'm not discounting
myself i've got enough on with the spy
right
um but i think the
i think the committee ought to have a
representative on and i think one of the
things we ought to do
is consider electing from our committee
who could go on that risk management
group so it's not not politically led
it could be for anyone from any group on
that's from our
committee that is chosen by audit to go
on to that group um and i think that's
something that perhaps we ought to put
on to our next agenda
so that we can agree somebody who should
be part of that risk management group
and also on the next agenda i would like
to see a framework confirm when those
meetings take place
uh so that we can see what sort of
topics are covered
in your forward plan that you've
referred to lee so that we can
mirror that in some of our agendas so
that we can actually discuss things in
advance of those risk management groups
and whoever our representative is could
also talk about that
um issue when they go to the the group
as well so add weight to
the papers that we are putting forward
so that's my view council shipment uh
might it be useful if we actually see
the uh different jobs of both of these
groups
uh because i mean i'm getting
the impression they're doing a similar
job although i would have thought that
the other group does the day-to-day
kind of overview of everything but
it comes here to be kind of signed off
as the scrutiny committee is that right
it's partly that way but if we're not
careful we'll have made it that way
because what we are not is a rubber
stamping exercise
the audit committee needs to scrutinize
ask those questions
and also um hold to account that's what
we're here for
so i think and rather than just
receiving it if it's old news
as some reports in the past have been
then
even if we have got valid points to make
it's too late decisions been made
and so i think it's a way of turning it
the other way around so that we can
actually be part of the the
thought-making process
and then even if it is you know as i say
if we've got the forward plan
we can try and put things in advance of
that risk management group so that
we can add to it if we want to
if we can still as an audit committee
still scrutinize anything that comes
from it
um so we get two bites of the same
cherry
that's all i see
mrs sternberg
thank you chair i don't know if this is
any help or not but your terms of
reference
include monitor the effective
development and operation of risk
management in the council
thank you that's it is that that's a
succinct answer
did you say that was ours sarah or did
you say that's the commit the other
group
no this is your terms of reference in
corporate government scrutiny
yes in other words we can roam where we
live
if we have the next meeting though we
have a what the risk management group
remit is because there'll be some things
that maybe
don't fall within audit then that's fair
enough but i think the things that do
and is listed at 1.9 there are plenty of
things that
are in our remit and it may be worth if
the committee decides ultimately that's
not what they want then that's
what we don't want but let's have more
information to make
an informed decision at our next meeting
is everyone in agreement with that
yes sure thank you
[Music]
any other council questions on the
report
it's not going to move to
recommendations at 6.1
can we have a proposal please
[Music]
thank you that is carried thank you so
much
seven reports to the head of the finance
and resources in the section 151 officer
you please jain corporate debt thank you
chair yes a journey
of posting my reports today this is the
standard report that the only committee
received with regards to corporate debt
that we did to the 31st of october to
align with the agenda
there's nothing major to report i'm
pleased to say um subject letters is
holding its own it was if you turn to
appendix one
on page 113 you will see rather a lot of
current debt sitting within that
um within that category 1.5 million i
just wanted to show the committee that
the majority of that was
a result of just a handful of invoices
the last committee is not reported as
part of this standard report
but we are um still pursuing
our recovery timetable with regards to
coving with regards to council tax and
business rates which is
it is challenging and we will continue
to report that to you through this
committee as
time progresses i'm not proposing to go
through all the detail unless anybody's
got anything that they'd like to ask me
specifically and
try and answer any comments or questions
if not then can we move to
recommendations at 6.1
that we know the report concerning the
council's corporate debt as the
third half the 31st of october 2020.
proposal please thank you and seconded
by council shipment all in favour
thank you that is carried so much to the
report b
benchmarking and i'm pleased to see this
has been brought thank you jim so
back to you no problem at all thank you
chair this is the report the committee
asked me to present
for this meeting at the last meeting and
it's very insightful doing it so i do
hope that you enjoyed reading it
and i won't go through all of it i know
i'm an accountant
it's all for everybody else interesting
for me i'm sure and
i won't go through all of the detail
because i wouldn't want you to
suffer from my affliction of being
obsessed with numbers but
um i will just pick out the highlights
if that's okay with you and run through
the
specific tables so what's been happening
since march is that
the ministry of housing and local
government mhclg have been collecting
data on a national basis
on the impact of kobe in terms of both
income and expenditure
so it's allowed us to be able to
summarise our position and analyze it
against what's happening nationally
i'm pleased to say that in the main we
are covering following the national
trend
largely and you will see on table one in
appendix one
that an additional expenditure of 3.6
billion pounds has been incurred by
local authorities in the first half of
the year
the trends tend to match the council
type so for example in districts it's
quite diverse
there's quite a wide spread of how the
um i was being incurred
and whereas with counties and those with
responsibility to social
care it's very much centered on that
particular
service that they provide moving on to
table
three that looks at the income losses
and this is the one that's affected us
the most so table three and table four
both present a position
of income losses um as you'll see from
the tables districts and those with
responsibility for leisure facilities
collecting council tax and collecting
business rates are being particularly
hard here
the the national position 4.6 billion
pounds is an awful
you know awful lot of money that we're
going to have to train some of it's
recoverable to be fair council tax and
business rates is quite recoverable
and the income loss from sales fees and
charges is gone and that that can't be
recovered
graph one plus the national position
regards council tax and business rates
losses i think it shows quite nicely
that there was a huge peak to start with
and then with council tax it has started
to flatten out a little bit now
business rates unfortunately
as you would expect
and graphs two and three um pie charts
which got a lot awful lot of information
on them but just to highlight really
that
our position is very much mirroring the
national position that
the main areas that we're losing out on
it's not necessarily an expenditure
issue for us
it's an income loss issue and you can
see that business rate
before i take any questions that you may
have
the housing revenue accounts across the
country and the same for us
aren't being that badly affected by the
kobe pandemic
rents collections pretty good it's not
that much lower than we would expect
it's only and the overall impact
compared to council's
general funds across the country is only
1.4
so if there is any any good news out of
all of this is that the council's house
and revenue accounts across the country
aren't being adversely affected so after
i've overloaded you in the bush chair
i'd be happy to take any questions
well yeah i think can we just come back
to a couple of bits of bad news yes
i think we can't carry on without
mentioning uh croydon
and i think people know croydon council
has issued a section 114 notice so
basically saying that they're bankrupt
and we have um a medium-term investment
with croydon
3 million
so i think we need to have a bit of a
discussion about that um i'm sure people
agree
and of course the second part of the big
news is the negative interest rate risk
i think we need to have a little bit
more detail about that so can i
bring you back to those two points
please certainly
and yes if it wasn't the best day when i
realized that we've got an investment
with corydon
um haven't discovered that they just
issued a section one one four notice
i have taken advice from our treasury
advisors on that and
um being assured that in actual fact
although
the 114 notice prevents future spend and
ongoing spend
which doesn't affect existing
investments so because we've already
invested with them because the duration
will almost undoubtedly exceed the
time for the sexual world for notice
they tend to be time limited to sexual
hormone foreign notices
until the resolution is made through
council to set a revised budget
um it it it is very unlikely that our
risk
we will have a higher risk than the day
before the sexual assault notice
so i you know i'd just like to offer the
committee's insurance
on that point three things unlikely
i think the committee would want to be
reassured as you say it is unlikely but
and we will be keeping a very close
monitoring of
what's happening with croyon i've said
this before and you may recall a couple
years ago i referred to
lending money to the councils um
it's part of our investment strategy and
we went to councils that i've questioned
previously and here we are now with an
example of one that's um
struggling for various reasons it won't
be the only one i'm sure
and and there's rumors of others that
are looking at section 114 notices
and i think our portfolio needs to think
about that and they're keeping one eye
to uh council investment and whether we
that's the way we want to be in the
future
and so i think i would welcome your
comments on that
yeah absolutely it's a very difficult
one for us because
um local authorities have always been
deemed along with
national government as the safest option
um
and now we're seeing situations whereby
i don't believe the risk is high for
local authorities
still particularly but we're seeing
unprecedented numbers of local
authorities who can't
balance their budgets so it does put a
new light on that um
the chair has asked me to invite the
treasury management consultants to come
to the next meeting which will also be a
meeting that will review the
the committee will review the uh annual
treasury management strategy so
i think there could be some interesting
debate around these points because it is
absolutely valid
it's very difficult to know where your
money is safe these days
yeah thank you and the negative
interest rate race yes this is an
interesting one we've not been that
we've not been hit by it yet
um interestingly enough the government
account the safest account there is out
there something called the dmadf
which is government government-backed um
funding is one of the first to go into
negative
um interest rates but it's on the
short-term stuff and we've been taking a
lot of money away for
a couple of months at a time so it's not
hit us yet but
it's almost undoubtedly at some point
going to impact on us and we'll actually
end up paying the banks to look after
our money which is
which is somewhere that i never thought
would think but um yeah
absolutely but keep an eye on that
thank you
any other counter armitage
uh thank you chair it's uh have we got
uh any other local authorities who've
loaned money from us uh on our portfolio
and don't we uh employ somebody to check
on
all of this and to get and to monitor it
i mean what have they been doing to let
us get dropped in with croydon in this
manner
yes we actually have we've got god's
support for a council and we've got
celebrate council although the slave one
has now
now exceeded uh ender sorry and
we do do an awful lot of due diligence
and we do employ treasury management
consultants who specialize in this
and the difficulty is until the section
151 officer
announces the 1-1-4 notice the credit
rating of any local authority will be
very very high it will be the best
rating that there is and it'll only be
if there's signs
through committee reports or internal
rumblings i guess
that we would actually the tr even the
consultants would get any
any inclination or any indication that
there could be a problem so
it's a very difficult one whereas with
industry you generally start to get
feel or a sign that something's just not
quite right
through the bluetooth companies and the
banks etc with a local authority until
the section 111
notice is served the credit rating would
remain higher so
but we are doing all the due diligence
that we can do
do we have any uh thumb back on these uh
people who have advised us i mean surely
you know
they're taking a fee all the time i mean
uh
are they covered with the third party
liability and
do we have a redress on this
okay do you test that we've gone into 18
but
we're covering two reports in one here
banning it for money
yeah they would be covered and we would
have redressed at this stage
there's there's no concerns so i don't
think that would be an issue
however if you did get into difficulties
you could rest assured
was some very tense conversations going
on between myself and the trillion
consultants over this matter because
because we do follow their advice
and we do seek their advice but i'm i am
i'm
i can't say 100 confidence
i don't perceive this as a risk to the
council i don't believe that the money
is at risk
i think if we're going into this today
then i would be saying
no we won't go anywhere near them having
said that there are the local
authorities that are still lending to
these councils because
they're still deemed a better um
risk than some of the banks across all
the high street businesses i mean we've
all seen what's happening this week
yeah get really sad as well so um i
think it's difficult to know where to
invest but
um and but that's uh
that's a question there questions we can
save for when we get the visit to the
next
meeting absolutely
any other comments or questions i think
the exercise
i will say in benchmarking has been very
useful and
i'm glad it's been done and i think it's
been useful for offices as well
i think in some ways reassuring
and there is good news in there as well
as those things that
highlights and some of the issues that
we do need to keep a very careful eye on
so having said all that can we move the
recommendations that 6.1 that we know
the report
the proposal please council club thank
you second by council armitage
all in favor thank you that's carried
so we know to the treasury management
update i think we've
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
questions for anybody else
this is all new
so if not most recommendations at 6.1
can we have a proposal please
thank you council shipment do you have a
second debt thank you council rowe
all in favor thank you that is carried
so now move to um item eight report to
the head of corporate government to
manchester united on the corporate
work plan
thank you chair um as the report says
this is
to enable you to consider your work plan
for the remainder of the municipal year
this is a living document it's not
static it gives a structure and sets the
dates for certain things you have to do
at certain times
and they're all encompassed within the
terms of reference the committee
if you actually turn to page 136 where
you've got the work plan
from today's meeting for example on the
20th of january we should add in the
mismanagement group
and your considerations on membership of
that and on the 10th of february meeting
in addition i would like to add a review
of the code of corporate governance
which is um
something i have to achieve by the end
of the financial year so it should be
coming to you in february
but other than that it's for comment
chair
this is the business management one as
well to the 20th of january that we
agreed after
looking at business risk yeah the
recovery of the recovery plans yeah
yeah yeah we'll add us into chair thank
you thank you really
could i just clarify you if you you want
the whole report again or just the uh
no no we said that we would drill down
into that bit because um
the priority needed to be mended and we
need to look at how
business recovery um is going to be a
bit more imminent
lovely um just in terms of fighting the
fraud and corruption locally
that just does depend on whether siffer
have issued their um results of their
survey or not they've not published it
yet
um if they publish it in time i'll bring
it to that meeting but otherwise there
might be a delay
if we leave it where it is but subject
to if you say there's a delay
we'll just put it back to the next
meeting after that and
thank you that's out of our hands isn't
it until
release it lee thank you chair
just just to be absolutely clear because
i don't want things to get lost in
translation
the the item that we were talking about
earlier on was business continuity
and emergency planning it emanated from
that medium
uh action that's
just to be clear that's different to the
outward facing business
recovery work so i just wanted to be
absolutely certain yes
what you needed yeah it's that part of
the plan
that's specific in that plan we just
want to drill down more information have
a
bit more of a detailed report about
what's behind it and and how we're going
to in this code situation
and
[Music]
questions about the work plan
they've got enough to be going on with
if not then move to recommendations 6.1
can we have a proposal
thank you council club seconded by
council aunty you're all in favor
thank you that's carried
and then item nine no other matters of
urgency
so item ten i move that the public be
excluded from the meeting during the
discussion of the following item of
business
to avoid the disclosure to them of
exempt information as defined in
paragraphs one and three
part one of schedule 128 to the local
government act 1972
as amended by the local government
access to information variation
order 2006. we have a second before that
please
thank you counter role all in favor
thank you that's carried so we need to
stop the live stream please
you